-♪♪ Hey Robot ♪♪
♪♪ Hey, hey, Robot ♪♪
♪♪ Hey Robot ♪♪
-Now, this is based on the rea
board game called
"Hey Robot" that you
can play at home.
it's like the
classic game Password,
but you play with
a smart speaker.
So, first, you pick
a card with a word on it.
Then you have to ask a questio
to get the smart speaker
to say that word
somewhere in its answer.
If it does, you get a point.
If it doesn't, then the othe
person has a chance to steal
We'll go back and forth
until someone gets it.
You up for this?
-Yeah, but it sounds hard.
-No. Here we go.
Okay, I will go first.
Here we go.
-Okay.
Okay, here we go.
It might be hard.
Alright, my word is "ostrich."
Ostrich. Alright.
Alexa, what bird
puts its head in the sand?
-Here's something
I found on the web.
According to trust.org,
the ostrich is said to --
-Yes!
[ Dinging ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alexa, stop. Whoo!
This is a fun game already
-Trust.org? Alright.
-Dude, I write for trust.org
-She said the word,
but her sources, I don't know.
Alright.
-Alright, you're up.
-Okay.
So, then I should say it first
-Oh, yeah.
-Okay.
My word is "club."
-Alright.
-Now, this could mean
many things.
Alexa, what is Bungalow 8?
-Bungalow 8 is a nightclub
chain created --
[ Dinging ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alexa, stop.
-Stop, stop.
-Nice call. Bungalow 8.
-Yeah, yeah.
The hottest club of 2009.
-I love that.
It's my turn. Here we go.
Oh, come on, now.
My word is "Alcatraz."
Oh. Alcatraz. Alright.
Alexa, movie, "Birdman of...
-I know about 25 Birdman movies,
including "Beauty Shop,"
"The Carter," "Baller Blockin',"
"Nicki Minaj: The Pinkprin
Movie," and 21 more.
[ Buzzer ]
-Wait a minute! Come on!
Wait. You didn't let her finish.
She had 21 more movies.
Come on.
-Wait a minute.
Did my ears deceive me
or was one of the movies
called "The Birdman of
Nicki Minaj"?
-You've never seen that?
Where were you?
-Is Burt Lancaster in
that one, too?
-Where were you born?
You've never seen
"The Birdman of Nicki Minaj"
-I know a lot of Birdman movies.
"Birdman of Nicki Minaj"
and 25 more.
-"Alcatraz" would be
on her list.
Alright, that's probably
the last --
Now it's up to you.
You can steal --
Oh, no, Alcatraz.
-Oh, I can steal it?
-Yeah.
-Oh.
Alexa, what prison
is outside San Francisco?
-Here's something
I found on Wikipedia.
San Quentin State Prison
is a California Department
of Corrections --
-No. Alexa, stop.
Alexa, stop.
Honey, honey.
Please, listen.
-You can't talk like
that to Alexa.
-No, you can't talk like that.
That's a lesson.
Don't talk like that.
-Alexa, I'm sorry, stop.
-Anyone guess this --
-What prison is called The Rock?
-What's that?
-Oh, that's good.
Alexa, what prison
is called The Rock?
-Rock, rock, rock, rock,
rock another.
[ Buzzer ]
-I don't know what's happening
I don't know what's happening.
Alright, we're gonna
lose that one.
We'll do the last one here
-Okay.
-This is you. It's a new word.
-Alright, this is a new word
You know what?
Let's not talk about
that prison.
No, honestly, it was a lot o
bad things happened there.
-That's true.
-Ha, ha, ha.
My word is "screw."
-Yeah, and since this is
the last word,
this is worth 100,000 points
Whoever wins this
is the champion.
-The word is "screw."
-Yeah.
-Now, what meaning
would she know most?
-No.
-Well, I'm not gonna --
-I know.
-It's family show.
I'm a decent man.
I would never do that.
-I couldn't see you doing it
-Alexa, turning of the blank
-Hmm. I don't know that.
-Okay. That's cool.
[ Buzzer ]
Wait. We were just talking
We were talking.
-I'm gonna say...
Alexa, a Phillips-head
is a type of...
-No. Phillip's head.
Newfoundland and Labrador
is not a type of.
[ Buzzer ]
-Alexa, flat-head blank driver
-The flathead catfish,
also called the --
[ Buzzer ]
-Stop, stop!
-Alexa, stop.
-Honey, honey, please.
-Alexa, stop, stop.
-Darling.
-Honey, please. Alright.
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, alright.
Alexa, what is a cocktail with
orange juice and vodka?
-I know about a number of
orange-juice-vodka cocktails
including sex on the beach
a screwdriver --
-Yes!
[ Dinging ]
I love you!
Alexa, stop.
John Mulaney, everybody.